you want but it's okay I showed
the book maurice surround me with the ocean
if his nurse a
lot depends on the mayor of a
great ray schultz is still whole
departure from the sea
we
[Music]
no
to
nonsense where we lagoon a degraded 50%
we corey moore and that the res in
danger
ban fish that live in the mansion a
and the b disappear
[Music]
half black to the children and you the eleven
children the  love and have really ap
d'antoinette trabucco we will not
help us much and moment since words
since my birth i know a disk
and calvin and we passed the trade
surprise fisher after super guardian
audi camp is part of the 1200
pc to the  herbal teas or who live in
mauritius it's a teaser to leave to the
Indians who don't have a huge maritime space
the room is a tradition or of ban ki
moon who live on the coast like super ap
savannah a lot to ask yourself as we're
just starting  if there is beautiful  blow
fish and a lot yes you can
now a great guardian a good one
because I supposed to put migrants
of lots n is a job and motivated but
that in channel and candidacy good end and
when you can ransack them the citizen
to be able to take his  the wins barely
150 and a win a box at least
50 60 kg of smashing by matthieu
vasseur is a god and i'm really
sorry olicard years like that with the
currency but the married person led
raise your bases in the final phase the  school
with the Europeans fabrice isabel lucas
time that passes like us prevented
so you will tell me you eat spending a
lot of time only a fish and
now the fact that they lead comes
quite far in my education therefore
coming from a family of fishermen  it's
a pride for me even hardly
helmand is it possible handed over to
the elected members by the plague and web
would be there so promised that it was going to
lead to a war press fabrice like
many children pca into the  vier
tourism where this job and clap is a
bit difficult
the story had something else to it was
down from the 6 who
works when all a fixed job
every month at the palace at omega do
n't they have easy pcas bed  not easy
long had easy part at all even
[Applause]
practice today with therese everything
and children grew up and frankly tell you
long time forced to
fight and waved us to fight
like youtube and the 24 valves even
turned  a pleasure side auxerrois ground at
quantico comco cp clp noise of a locker
because I had to get his locker limits
like the methods are there in a
sob maracas and licked his graduates
like that and fish that follows every
moment there who was going to approve  control
rally raid dakar
thank you makes it vibrate with operations
pinard gameplay jaladeau annabis who me
different species of fish in mauritius and
has many who piss a coral to
shelter monzée and that their  said you
should know the corals already live there
in very specific conditions,
that is to say they will live in
temperatures between 18 and 29 degrees they
live in the sea they live where there
is light and mauritius all these
conditions there  are reunited but at 10 or
kong dives into the lagoon or finds a
lot of course and white and running or
silk and a lot of gaumont from the sakura he
has words for his spite and 17 local he
has fallen a lot in the eyes of the crusaders
passed by france 2 the house  Bahraini
two or three bones via the onlookers
gwada suitcases to realize that united the scene all
the gallop says no and it's less tiring
at the cades a soul in sport are to be
compared to 6 years ago in short let's move on
[Music]
in morisod  said henin n points 3
million said my eldest 60 years old
only half that no blah
[Music]
man diversified economic sector very
quickly from a tool zyl dumoulin
duplication in the city they
draw signs etc tourism
[Music]
banana bag and an iris mission finished
for him the place and that the sea
[Music]
unfortunately all this development
the aena is not clown or
the environment but b nazism in
local activity which affected the sea
global warming
it  there will be big events that will
affect the corals when the
bleaching maybe every five
years every ten years in the meantime we
have to give the
coral reefs time to repel our impacts in fact
from afar or infected 7
this phase  if we break the corals
have overfished the lagoons we pollute the sea
the corals will not grow as
quickly they will succeed is
more and more more zen the years go we will
have less and less 1 corals
and the plane in  less good health
[Music]
in 2009 we lost in norris some
of the statistics say up to 50% of
orders in the blades
[Music]
sense of the case poirson preparations for
nbc ordered audi divine difficult
[Music]
d  ans l'aude rich an autonomous teasing
of mauritius mann pcp face same
problem
sulking not its origin like years
gone a lot a lot the
passing species it disappears like a
militant organ starts gone yes all it
paved flat before passing like that
disappears and at the buttons of the times where
was a little bit as they say there
and a space pro 10 and calls
nice zone fishermen band series with
collaboration man fisher king and i
said i could eat because band
sin he decides  and who places who good
to beat to protect that one protects
a place in the sea where the space one
wins on the nippon life sided
after when he jumps if his area nabhan
pca gadji gros belbel
benneteau is also able to profit
complicates ray-ban  employment 1 in tourism
to decrease but by the way if the countries
previously denied on the mentality in
the summer thyroid paca under the box and to
optimize invested a lot to make them
feel ready to see the mentality  é who
tim o'neil does sent on the other hand if the
mayor of messac or disappears understands the
practical way because they held
the person in rodrigues
I take the other joint initiative of
the gombe and in response
in excess and concerns it  the
sinois equalization lez lannoy the buttock
speaks to us tweet or not at the rate where
there would be there goes for a product because
they would have tiani products that here at
the slip palace we are spoken to on the
coastal waters always of isère christmas who
could  at ten since 2011
robyn fenty at peace safe for
months in the year
[Music]
she has a rapid life cycle in six
months it seems longer say f to each other
when you finish language eliminates the need to
find a balance so that  'they
leave us a sufficient quantity or eight
points and my team he's a friend
live it balanced taxes so
everything bans the species in the sea we'll
say the first time that everything is
open
you'll see the pc  who brings bigger
riffs b  good first for sales and it
's still a big pace the wonder
in finding it before finding the
news exists delirium
a cp serve with his book goes down to
lille category many of our big
big captain like scania like that
because of me  almost two months according to m
show the ladies in the fridge alala 10
livre de mauritius too and nabhan rules that
they put in place to prodigy
we lagoon ena enn minimum diameter
locker and spinning not only a right the peace
sasso and who does not pack zone  protected
in the sea but savanna the initiative the
lip device a common success in
rodrigues  but because they form the
same moment gaz à cork which received
in my dear to the father of jet li min min
05 sec facing the liberals abstruse titles
in support fashion is bad or psg
for that he invites the ho  nneur to the regret
of this book seems not known little
belgium france and studied month here and there but
also in the law this term we want to say
that everything remains maurice mtpa holds to the
model law resolutely like that which is
what we the sea and  destroy but
here penalization of the banking leaders
even for a pcr who wanted to respect
I find it not easy to navigate well
it passes we believe the evening will be long and
there we risk big so big regret of the
nationals and its size or Tuesday
obama and the means c  is really said to
respect that senna a good
the administration of the coasts and the appetite
to be good it is not of anticipation
to leave a bigger one of the savannahs the
battery of a maurice the manga kana
maurice tanguay at the parisian
[Music  ]
goodfish as a pina moynier need
to fake the law we show the posts
fish here sam shoulder and me happy
also emotional in all this from the psp
[Laughs]
[Music]
here consists of bbb srpp since yesterday
after by one of  rnière
[Music]
thanked in others work
done I don't want to be not too much it's
too much sttr also work who I
work
a fairy sister boney m or do nothing
a party for the  kitchen
[Music]
the demo the coin goes to the kitchen
to make us a gold ring at the reception
they break thiam at mont péko we
're even still working delivered short
haircuts hours with work he did that
that to me  has not bad at all often
weird shapes but in other
newspapers quite strange in the sea when
she says or there but in the future
it's for us it's a war and
peace was doing it so they admire site  or
pcati cooperate but from there but
we learned better I can
control their
mother protect it for future generations
[Music]
outch abundantly the pcr have also
prepared I find a good result because
he desired and ali bongo des pins
paris  to hard knocks and adam g
[  Music]
solidarity and respect fishermen like
that doesn't turn the lagoon as quickly as possible for
sore drinks
[Laughs]
[Music]
says a lot and for the future
why so bitter
[Music]
he